hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three scary games
welcome to inheritance I don't know what
I'm inheriting but it's either going to
be a haunted house a haunted mansion a
haunted cabin in the woods or a haunted
former pet who's secretly not alive
maybe all right let's find out what am i
inheriting oh it's a house
oh it's haunted house oh it's most
indubitably a haunted house hello hello
hello welcome to your new home
I know it could use a bit of cleaning
but I hope it serves you well as it
served your grandpa and I after he
passed away I didn't know what to do
with the house but we both discussed
leaving it to you if we both were to
pass okay thanks grandma
thanks meemaw by the way is your haunted
ghost and/or corpse still in here you
two sure did live in squalor
I don't even visit you a lot grandma Oh
something strange under the rug please
don't pee a pentagram just a
funkalicious feeling it might be a
pentagram
all right cool it's probably not maybe
not there's something strange under this
rug but it's so unbelievably heavy I
couldn't possibly lift it all right
grandma
grandma grandma ah grandma stogies oh
wait no it's a box of candles this door
is locked I thought it was my house oh
good
ah Mimas single bed you know they didn't
sleep together they what do you think
I'm about to do don't do it
well meemaw you know I sure do love your
cryptic blood-stained messages but maybe
this once you could not do the blood
stain messages really prefer not to have
the writing on the walls and the such as
like it all hey good go great all of
your love notes oh yeah my grass Glen
have you in my life I'm sorry oh good
very good I'm sorry you know it's okay
it's okay
all right picked up a strange object to
me breathing its closes door in on
myself a tiny box Tim are you doing it
yeah cutie-patootie alright anyway I'll
just keep breathing Oh God ah don't do
it I don't know what I'm doing I don't
exactly know what I'm up to what kind of
shenanigans do you think I'm gonna
endure procure enabled oh god its lit in
here
it's lit him here all right let's move
oh it was indeed a pentagram is this
grandpa's blood I'd recognize it
anywhere all right
candle sorry book box candle candle
candle
candle and candle
oh that is delightful Oh what were you
saying
don't do it ice kind of too late I kind
of already did it can you stop flapping
excuse me ow ow oh just shimmy shakey I
had to he won't leave
I had to grandpa he won't live oh oh
maybe this was a bad idea it might have
been a bad idea all right hey my charge
to you charge that yo I love what a
monster deposes they're waiting for me
to write yet their face so those
inheritance quite good quite good a
little spoopy a little bit on the spooky
side of things I like it I like it I
like it a lot not too shabby if I do say
so myself
all right welcome to disorientation I'm
not a hundred percent sure what the
premise is with them with a lot of these
indie horror games you're just dropped
into an environment you're unfamiliar
with in you're expected sir well hi
hello how are you oh I love my slappy
boot steps very slappy why do I have an
eyeball in the middle of my screen mmm
dead end
yes oh hi hello sir how are you oh nice
to meet you
oh you're gonna make me out
disorientated aren't you oh I bet you
are
oh I bet you are thump swamp swamp thump
hello hello hello is anybody there okay
this is strange
only a little bit not on a percent sure
well hi how you doing there kalam why no
oh I can't move forward right what do
you do it's stupid pieces of poop you
think you can mess with me
oh hi okay you know okay all right sure
yeah give me a give me the spooks give
me the spooks baby give me the spooks
hello give me them spook spook all over
me spook
that is an uncomfy family that's Rio
it's on comfy oh yeah daddy's oh that's
horrifying horrifying I don't like it I
don't like it okay all right
oh no school lockers the most terrifying
thing I've ever seen
I am I supposed to I think I have no
choice
- what go back to school so let's cool
let's go where'd you just rob a dude was
there a sewer grate that I didn't see
probably nice real dark I don't like how
dark this is really dark real dork it's
real door it's really dark really really
fork it's like super the work it's so
dark
okay so what's down here it's given me
more spooks than any other thing in any
horror game ever leaky steam pipes it's
locked
I could no okay glad I was there to give
me false hope into finding out where I'm
supposed to go Oh
oh you did oh you poopy tip steam give
me more steam bus now at me maybe
[Music]
I hate you I hate you I hate you I hate
you I hate you you suck you Biggs don't
look at me stop looking at me you suck I
hate you I hate you I hate you so much I
don't know why that one got me so bad
that got me really bad okay moving on
moseyin Oh little zoo ball Mario pipes
tile just get sucked right up in there
I don't even have a choice I don't think
I clambered up there I don't know how I
could Oh for long oh no oh no I'm in the
dork woods
oh no not the dark woods Oh No
how did I get here it's so dark I can't
see
he's dirt I'm sorry I came over
apps are excuse you I don't need this in
my life Hey
it was only a dream haha only a dream
where am I
all right the only a dream begin with
some my mole ticks alright only a dream
man only a dream easy-peasy only a
dreamy wavy last job I got an upgrade my
boots if leveled up twice's thumpy edit
texture that's right I got a key
I don't know it good that does me it
texture okay good it maybe you should
have the texture oh I did it wait a
minute wait a minute wait okay all right
that's weird well oh hi hello
[Music]
okay let's turn that noise off there
come unusual of jams I turned you off
you stay off oh you want to fight about
this buddy you wanna fight huh get so me
yeah you think you can mess with me you
can mess Morgan please game baby
yeah you better I'm watching no I'm
not ah okay alright well I certainly am
its orientated where is ending what game
doesn't contain full ending because of
school full ending will be available
wait maybe that's seven 9s in now still
that was a while ago I guess it won't
have a full ending oh I'm sorry
well thank you developer for making that
one that was very good it had a lot of
really cool things anything it did get
me really bad with one of those things
which just shows those to show you don't
always need a big booming jump scare to
get you you don't you don't always need
a big booming jump scare so that's
pretty good I like that a lot
so anyway moving on welcome to prom
Nisha prom Nisha when you add such a
terrible time at prom that you do
anything to forget it
romnesia anyway
for a better experience use headphones
Bob I'm a BIST
all controls are required to use at
least one pay attention and narration
prompt it on the screen you can pause
the game I did a lot of weird
instructions in a weird rumbly in the
background either that or it's a rumbly
in my tumbly but I'm sure we're gonna
feel old two years ago
police received reports of a home
invasion at 10:15 p.m. they arrived on
the scene to a mother and daughter
murdered but no forced entry was
suspected after six months of
investigation the case went cold the
father now lives alone even though two
years have passed these stills and moved
on it's your fault they're gone if only
you didn't value a job more than your
family if you didn't work more than
spending time with your family perhaps
they would still be alive that's sad
probably not my fault why would it be my
fault I didn't do it maybe I don't know
oh
open they can doors door am I really
gonna get tutorial on doors really open
they can offer a chance for something
new closed you're stuck with what you
got so what was that about open doors
who will open nope it's nothing I went
up to a decal on the wall because I'm an
idiot now well this is a
there's a weird house so is this my
house Oh green I hate that color I spent
too much time thinking about muddy and
it cost me my family's life it cost me
the money I sure do love money
oh sweet delectable money money
hello who's that the money monster oh
hello
was that my voice am i squeaking like a
mouse here why was that TV on why is
there TV on the ground anyway it's a lot
of problems here Oh fun drawing
okey-dokey then
all right you know
the answer to the question you are
asking is you know everything's fine
this is normal this is perfectly normal
where's the music coming from I don't
know it's your house why don't you turn
off your haunted music boxes whoa how
are you okay yeah yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's normal just everything was
it's a little weird oh that's even weird
wha hey Wiggly whoo
how you doing wiggle waggle you uncomfy
in your bed oh you don't like your
little knapsack oh what's wrong your
sleeping bag a little too tight ooh
someone's dreaming oh look he's having a
good dream
okay now this thing this portal ass
here sorry bull poopy I think
the I mean it's cool facts I guess it
seems to be all right here we go green
the color of money love which I like
very much so I love money
hello Oh looks like I'm stuck with what
I have
looks like I'm stuck with what I have
and also a weird stain on the ground I
like weird stains weird stains are my
favorite thing you suck I am not scared
by the likes of which of that alright
hey this is normal coloured but this is
green there's an odd note in the frame
Oh what does it say buddy
press eatery the note do you love this
place isn't safe and you must escape as
soon as you can pay attention to the
time as you don't have long oh I don't
have a watch I don't see a clock
I'm sorry
want to run that by me again
okay you guys heard that right
Oh hide or are you okay you guys can't
lie to me you definitely heard that
right you definitely did the hearing
after that oh hey how you doing okay
well you know I didn't want to go
through the Orient oh oh this side oh
well never mind no not that
how about I'll be hearing how about uh
peace tears II how about I go up in
stairs okay no I guess never mind maybe
I go out the front door maybe that's the
trick maybe I leave this horrible place
I can move on I can move on real good
hey what's happening over here why is it
all flickery I don't remember this being
this flickery before I don't remember
this being this flickery at all I don't
remember any of the flicker flashers oh
hey now your normal colored not green
like the color of money okay cool
all right well I don't know what you
expect me to do about any of this I
don't exactly have a clock so I can't
pay attention to the time I can't pretty
change do anything all right
it's gonna go pay attention to the time
oh there's a clock oh it's only 10:15
all right easy peasy it's like nothing
it's like nothing up I barely go to bed
at 10:15 I don't do nothing at 10:15 I
don't know what's happening here I don't
know what is wants from me
okay so something's Oh about all this
I'm not a harvester sure what he's all
but dum-dum main right here
gobby something that a clock no it's a
lamp it's one of those lamps
oh it's 10:15 what I needed to look at
it oh wait was why why why whoa why why
why why what
whoa oh
what well oh dang it I can't help but
feel I'm not the only one that's a
little disappointed about that it was
going so good I was feeling so spoopy I
don't know why I did that but I was
feeling so spoopy and you know no I'm
not so that was three scary games hope
you enjoyed it if you did let me know
down in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching and check
out all the other scary games that I
have available in the description and if
you want more scary stuff why not check
out my story podcast filled with scary
scary stories linked in the description
it's called the edge of sleep why not
try for yourself thank you everybody so
much and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]